[Music]
ah
hello, good afternoon everyone,
thank you very much for being here. I'm going to come up with a
first solution, which is that
everything in here has a lot
of information and you don't know where to
store it, so I have to
confess that I've  I cheated a bit
with him with the title of the presentation
and actually the question mark I am going to
make a bit of a syntactic change and in
reality the presentation would be of this
style my goal is that at the end of the
session you will have a clear idea of
to store your  data and
logically that it be in google cloud
cloud platform no so that is my
objective now getting a little
more serious about the main objectives of
the session
and comment with you and share a
general vision of the services that
from google cloud platform we
propose around the  storage and
databases I will do it not looking
exclusively at products to products
but I will try to give you a reference  s of
architectures of examples
of customer use cases
we will also share as we are aware that there are
many components depending on the
needs of each one of you
choosing one or the other can be more or less
complicated because we will share with
you a tree a kind of tree
of decision in which we see and in which
we help each other we will go to choose the best
option according to your needs and
our
friends are also customers and partners of sutter
cloud who will share with you a
specific experience on one of the components
of  The solution is
very good, well, to begin with, let's go.
Before we begin to see product by
product, I would like to share with
you what needs and
use cases we are seeing in our clients
in everything that has to do with data
and storage.  of use of
customers who are using
cloud technologies to
respond to their needs also  hen I
would like to give more context and to
give more meaning to the explanation
of each of our products, to make
a little history and see the evolution
that we have had throughout
technology in all these types of
solutions, both storage
and  database talking about history
because in front of you you have a
guy with quite a bit of history in this in this
field I started working with versions
of oracle 5 that many of you are
much younger than me and surely you
had not heard of them
but the
evolution that
these technologies have had over time never ceases to amaze me, I
remember and I quite agreed
with a colleague of mine who had
been telling me for a long time, but if this
computer science thing is always the same, it's reading and
writing, reading and  writing not of everything but it
never ceases to amaze you that even
being literate that we now have the
ability to read so much information to
write so fast  how we can
write and manage so much
information and of such a diverse nature
well on this island you see some cases
of clients and use cases
needs that our clients are
beginning to solve through the
cloud in reality if you take a
look at many  of them are not really
new needs, they are needs
that we have and have had in
companies over time,
what is true is that some of them
were very difficult to respond to some
time ago and now we are beginning to be able to
respond  to them
with calculation capacity
with storage capacity and what is allowing us
in many cases is not only to
improve processes, not only to make them
faster and more efficient, but in some
cases even to do
new things, totally managerial things,
even from  These
technologies are creating new
businesses that a few years ago were
impossible or very difficult to
imagine.  To
give you an example
in the area of airlines I don't know if you know
hat the majority of engines the vast
ajority of airlines have rolls
royce engines I give this example it is on
of our clients the m
del that works with the one that works
with rolls royce from the point  From the point of
view of the airlines, it is not that the
engine is owned by the airlines and
it is still owned by
Rolls-Royce for various reasons, among
some of them I do not imagine that it is
financial, which escapes me, no, the other
reason is because Rolls-Royce wants to
maintain a  control and
operational information of all these motors, then
at the level
of telemetry sensors, it is
constantly collecting information on the
operation of these motors and with
this what it achieves is a predictive analysis, it
manages to anticipate
possible problems and what it does is
extend the time of  life of these
motors these types of use cases that
we will see some in our in our
clients are being solved a little  or
with these new technologies and in the cloud
we have examples in the media area,
for example, they are very
typical in terms of large volumes of
information handling large volumes of
information and serving
that information efficiently in the
retail sector all  what it has to do with
analysis customer analysis analysis
of product recommendations in
financial services apart from the
financial transactions themselves but
we found cases of use of
risk management in
market operations markets in the
energy and construction area many examples
also related  with telemetry with
collecting information, for example, from
meters in homes and information
almost in real time in the gaming area,
of course, everything that has to do
with customer loyalty and in
health services, to put another, of
course, another case, everything that has  to
do with records the management of
digital records in short a
mo  A lot of cases that I already said existed in
the past but that we were not
perhaps capable of giving them an answer like right
now we are being able to give in
terms of evolution in both
storage and database
if we look at storage
we start  All at once we started with a
very monolithic design, that is to say, the computation or
the machine had both the
computation part and the storage part,
all together,
we evolved to
sanz and nash systems where we
decoupled the part  of
computing of what is the warehouse part,
we used the network for the communication
of both environments, which allowed us
greater flexibility and today
remote storage systems in the cloud with
agile interfaces are more common and there are
flexible interfaces and  light for access to that
information we will see that one of our
cloud storage solutions falls within
this category in terms of  as
databases
well, those of us who have already told you have
been working with databases for a
long time is we have to
admit that a few years ago I am talking about
quite a few years we had it perhaps a
little easier because because
we knew in advance the structure of
the  data that we were going to handle
we knew a little about the volume that we
could expect there were no changes in
terms of storage as drastic
as there may be now with the appearance
or with the intensive use of the internet the
purpose of the information that
we were handling because we knew it
beforehand  we could know if it was going to be
more oriented to transactionality or to
a more data warehouse-oriented design,
we had information transfer elements
between one world and another between
the transactional part and the
data warehouse part and obviously we have and
had and have systems, well, very
powerful and very good solutions on the
market from oracle ibm microsoft era
data have all  das magnificent solutions
in this sense the little bit of change
or inflection occurs when the
appearance of big data big data a little bit
of ezkaba to dig into all this there
is no need to deal with a lot of
information very heterogeneous information
very changeable
to its structure and  solutions arise,
such as hadoop,
the need also arises based on
to respond to the need for
horizontal scalability, many times
thinking of applications that are
accessible through the internet
mobile or web applications and in
which the data the data structure  It
was not as clear as before because
the need arises and the response of the
market, let's say about technology, are
non-sql databases, which as many of
you know, because it does not sneak in, sometimes it
is not only sql, no, and then these
databases normally  that give an
answer is horizontal scalability
even having a small penalty in
terms of consistency
and finally say  Let's see if we see the
benefits of the world of
transactional relational databases and we see the
benefits of sql databases
because not having the best of both worlds
and a little while anticipating one of
the solutions the answer that
google gives to this unknown  or this wish is
google spanair we will see it
I imagine that you have had the
opportunity to see the demonstration
in the keynote if not I invite you to later
have a specific stand where we
can show you that demonstration with more details
well then we are going to review  each one
of the solutions each one of the
products that we have for each of
the specific needs and as I already told
you for each one of them will
introduce at least one example architecture
or use case to make it
easier to locate it in  one
in one case or another
we start with our binary
object storage managed service we
call cloud storage and
we have four different types  of
storage within this
multi regional regional near line service and with
line
the difference between these types
basically responds to the level of
demand for access that we have to the
information I begin by differentiating multi
regional and regional multi regional and
regional we are going to use it whenever
a content when they are some files
that we are going to need to access or
update more or less
frequently the difference between the two is
that multi-regional we ensure
replication between different
google data centers while in the
regional there will be replication but at  level
only of region only of a
data center with replica in the zones the
different zones that this data center has
then depended on your
demands in terms of high
availability in anticipation of a
disaster that God forbids to happen
but that destroys or  that can destroy
an entire data center because we will have
to go to a multi-solution  i regional
the types or airlines and with line they are
for are more suitable when we have
less needs for less
frequent access to information on go line
we are talking about months a few months and
with line when that content well
you are going to access it let's say one  once a
year this is on average logically there are
cases for specific cases the difference between
all basically is the price the price
of storage and the price
of network consumption when you access them
then before making a design and
choosing a container or  Another thing is that you have to
do a little analysis of what it is
that gives me the times that I am going to access
that content of the amount of
information that I have and with that you get
the balance quite clearly one of the
most interesting things that lived in
storage  at the beginning it is the fact
that the api and the performance are
uniform that is to say regardless
of the type of container the celery is the
same and the performance you get is
the  Even the access interfaces are
several from the console that you can
manage and create the packages, which is how
we call the containers, we
have vip access and as I say, and also
a command line utility that
allows me to manage and access the
information and  there is a very
interesting aspect but I do not want to step on the
presentation to antonio that is about the
life cycle, that is, an
automated way of managing the
life cycle of those contents of those files
inside our containers
the first use case with such storage
it is a typical use case in companies
that have to handle a lot of
information a lot of content and have to
provide have to deliver that
content in a very efficient way to
their clients here apart
from data ingestion processes in which we have
solutions with third parties that  They allow us,
for example, to bring
information stored on hard drives
directly to our our network in
this  type of use cases,
the network infrastructure that
you have below is very relevant and
we are applying this use case internally in
google products such as
youtube,
so how can I tell you the combination of
cloud storage with the different types
of storage according to  the level of
accessibility plus the
network infrastructure that allows us, in addition to
google's own network backbone, the
access points that ensure that
the user's request will be
answered at the closest
possible point in their connection to  internet
combined with cache elements, either
google's own, such as cdn or
third-party products with agreements that we have,
for example, easy and that is one of
our partners that is present today
in next, what we achieve is
very efficient delivery of content in
the second  use case is associated with
all any
information analysis processes in these in
these basic processes  There are basically three
phases: the digestion phase, the
analysis phase, and the delivery or visualization phase.
In this type of scenario, a
concept appears that we call a data lake, which
is a definition of a container of
information that will be fed from
different sources.
sources can be as you see on
the left can be
ingested today added to the container in
batch form or in stream form
examples of ingestion in string mode
as we can find them in the
acquisition of information from
social networks in which they are
constantly changing information that  it comes
from lots of internet of
things devices etc. if we have an ingestion
of information through stream mode
let's say normally normally and this
is a reference architecture what we
need is to transform that
information and that transformation we have
tools we also have components
within the solution  how is data flow
is based on the standard  ar apache beam
that we can define
the information transformation and processing pipeline in
the end all the information ends up
in the data lake and the data lake
what is going to be for me in turn is an
information provider for
subsequent analysis processes other
tools such as match in learning, for
example,
thinking about the delivery and visualization part,
we found and found it
interesting to share with you this
use case that if we
need to display information from
a data warehouse solution, for
example, bit query bit query can
Through a feature
called federated queries,
directly access the information we
have in class, explore and display it when
displaying it, or engage with
third-party tools or even data studio, which is
from Google to define and display
reports, dashboards, etc.,
etc.,
another case  of use what to do with the data
that I have in my infrastructure for
example how  how to take advantage of the capabilities
of the cloud that we have seen cheaper
highly available
I have quick access to information
how to make the migration or
coexistence in a simple way and in
a way that is as smooth as possible
good for these use cases in which
as  we have called there we are is a
hybrid use case we have information
still on premis and we will have information in the
cloud if we so decide we have
different partner agreements with
partners in each of the use cases
if we talk about ingestion as I was saying
we have agreements with some of  the
companies that you see there to take the
information that we may have stored
on hard drives directly to our
network if we are talking about
backup and disaster recovery solutions we have
integration with products such as veritas such
as cloud barry and if we are talking
about archiving solutions, for example
If, for example, you have a solution such as
net app
or mc and you have part of the information  ion
that you decide because that information that
you are going to access unless you can archive
in the cloud you can continue using
this type of tools so that in
a transparent way you manage both
the information that was planned and
the information that is in our in
our cloud
well we have seen  the first solution that
is oriented to container of
binary files let's see now what response
we have to solutions of type
transactional database or
relational database our solutions cloud sql
auto that is to say that it is a
relational database managed service
we can use two  types of engines or
mysql or post gres that is currently
in beta version what we offer you here
is a self-automated management from
the point of view of
backup updates of security patches etc.
etc.
that does not mean that what you have is
a black box  and that you can not access
the database to the database instance
co  nfigure it define the
corresponding schemes do the
corresponding tuning of the database
whatever you need but let's say the
most typical maintenance operations
we do them or we do them in
a completely managed system
what use case we find here in
general any application that
needs a  relational database
here we have included an example of
e-commerce where we can
have the front end served by
a beijing or even by
typical tools in this world such as
wordpress as a group etc etc etc
we have a
cloud sql database instance  which would be the master instance
with inventory control
from there we can have a replica with
write-write or
read-only replicas to ensure high
availability and in this example what we
have defined is a
read-only replica to serve  the
information part to the reporting part
to the  part of dashboards
so that it does not affect me or affects me as
little as possible to the operational
claudia text claudia tractor is a
database to a
non-sql database managed service we said that
sql databases were
the objective they were pursuing  or the
need they were trying to cover is high
horizontal scalability even at the cost of
penalizing consistency
and also being more flexible in terms of
structure and admitting types of
document-type structures or files based on
xml
jason etc. etc.
This service is highly optimized for
web applications for
mobile applications the main advantage of this
database is, as I was saying, the
scalability of autoscaling, you
don't have to worry if you start an
application accessing 10 users and
you have a peak of 1000 or you go up to a
million, the solution scales as you go
that you need it
is therefore transparent to the
application and the licensing mode,
let's say or payment is  absolutely pay
per use you are only going to pay for what
you are consuming
if you have peaks or valleys
in accessing your application that time
and that process time you
are going to save it
there are many especially in
web applications  for mobile applications in the
gaming environment there are many cases
many examples of architectures of this
style in this example that we have
included all the part of both
the front end part and the
back-end part could be containers and as
you can see the  characteristic or singularity
of this architecture is that the
database instance is unique here we
are not talking about multiple replicas
directly from the point of view of
application from the point of view of
services in this case the database
is unique and the  scalability is
absolutely automatic
we have included a reference to a
product that if any of you are
developers of mobile applications
you will surely  it is familiar because
fire veis is one of the
most used products by this community
within the services offered by fire
veis apart from that of specific cases
for each of the android platforms
that javascript in client mode one of
the services is a
real-time database this real-time database,
apart from another series of services,
its main characteristic
is to respond to the
typical offline use case when someone is
using a mobile application and
has no connection what we have  What to
ensure is that you can continue
using it, that is, you have
access to the data and, on the other
hand, when you have a connection again,
we are able to ensure that
synchronization
and ensure that the data that you have been able to
modify offline is uploaded to the cloud and
vice versa,
a use case  typical are
messaging applications in which we can
not always be at the expense of we have to
have a certain autonomy and therefore  or less
allow messages to be written
and delivered when there is a connection or
we are able to have a minimum
database configuration in the
mobile application that allows us to continue
working as you can see in the scheme
we use and it is one of the
different advantages we have  a specific sdk
for each of the environments and
also
another of the services such as
fire veis analytics we can
collect usage statistics and
this component has an integration
with another of the
google data warehouse solutions that is  bic wear
and we can make a sports of the
information from fire veis analytics
avid query for later exploitation
big table here we are talking about a
managed service it is also a
non-sql database a managed service the
analytical database we position vic uvic
table in situations  in which the
requirements in terms of reading and writing
are very large and we are working
with volume  s very large in information,
just as surely as many of you who
have worked with databases,
even as database administrators
or adjusting databases, surely
the term full scan is familiar to
you and you get nervous when
that operation that  The database throws me away
because, for example, one of the
advantages it has and the
great functionalities it has is
the ability to
scan the database very quickly,
this victim, as we have done
with other products, we opened the code in
2006  we put a beige h interface in it
so that it would be easier to
integrate with other solutions and
actually opening up the code at
that time has served to
develop other
non-sql type solutions, in fact when I told you about
spanair spanair uses part of
let's say it from the definition of the same
definition with which big time ball was created
one of the typical cases for big table
is  internet in any case a
use case related to the internet of
things when we have billions of
devices sending information
normally
we capture that information with an element as you can see there
which is for sap which is a
message manager the advantage it has is that it
is  a global service
we are able to send
information from telemetry sensors
from anywhere in the world that is going to
access the instance or the service to
pass at the closest point of
connection from there the information
would be in the google network normally
in  this type of scenario arises
data transfer needs in
batch mode or data transfer
in stream mode for stream mode
we have discussed it previously our
solution is data flow for batch mode
we have a hadoop
and spark managed service in case of  that the client was already
working with them
at the end from both points of
view both  e bach how as a stream they would arrive
we would make the
corresponding inserts and updates
in big table and from here we have two
options you
saw bolt it is accessible it is accessible
via
aph beige but perhaps it is not
such a simple mechanism as flexible as sql can be
no then what  we have is an
integration in the form of
federated queries as we saw in the case of vic
query and cloud storage that allows us
from bit query to access the information
we have in big table and from
there show it with the
visualization tool that we want
well and how  It counted as I mentioned
before because not having the
best we came from each house the
relational database part the
non-sql database part because our
answer to this question or this wish
is cloud spanair spanair arises
internally as a
nosql database  it has been used by google
for several years there are already services
like adwords and there are others that are being
migrated  I know that they are using this
database and what we have done
over the years is to evolve it and with
that let's say non-sql origin we have
put an sql interface and we have ensured
the data consistency part with
which with spanair  what you have is a
service
and highly scalable
horizontal scalability and absolute consistency between
all the between all the nodes
we have the capacity as you may have
seen in this morning's demo and
even hot schema modification
without having to stop any of
the nodes imagine this  type of
applications or use cases of
architectures in which we have an
application that we are updating
from multiple geographically dispersed sites,
even this application has different entities,
such as in a
supply chain, because the inventory, the
orders, the logistics issue on a daily basis
today with traditional solutions
we would obviously have that it is possible
but there would be  to set up an
infrastructure and communication a
synchronization and some references to some
quite complicated replica configurations with spanair everything is
much simpler from the administration point
of view to create a
database is to define the number of nodes and
the regions where we want  that they are
deployed
and we can even control that scalability
and we can automate it
based on process monitoring
and finally
the component, let's say the solution,
our data warehouse solution in the
cloud, which is big query big query the
characteristics that one of the
characteristics has  The main ones is the
speed to make an aquarium in big query
on terabytes of information
the result is a matter of seconds
the scalability is absolute we say
internally we have a comment that
is I have a lot of data I load all the
data in big query and I start to
consult them and add more data  and
I keep consulting I don't have to  do I do not
have to anticipate increases in storage I
do not have to anticipate an increase in
virtual machines etc in scalability it is
exceptional
as a reference or as a
reference architecture particular use case because
we have the exploitation of logs for
example the one that we have different
systems or different devices that
go  leaving information about what we
treat them the same as we have seen in the
other case with a messaging system and
we add the information in vic query the
difference between vic query ivic de table
in in this case my which is more designed
for information aggregation rather than
to update records
very well you will have told yourself by many there are
many components there are many
logically each one and each
use case because it has an application then
without going into much detail on each
of the components what we have
well shared what  we are going to
share with you a kind
of decision tree which component to
use before  e concrete needs
I start at the top structured data
that is to say I am managing files here
the decision if I go to the left
would be if the application that I am
building is that I need it to be
accessible from mobile if it is from
I need from from mobile I can
take advantage of the capabilities of  fire
you see in terms of specific interfaces
for ios for android and I would use fire
you see chinese stora cloud storage
the next question is
if I have a strong need
for data analytics if it is if it is so the
difference between using the decision between
using victor or  big query is more in
need of updating and
absolute low latency requirements
if so i will be using big time bold
if it is more of an information aggregation issue it
would be bit query the next
question would be on the core tree
if i have relational data yes or  no if i
have relational data my question is going
to be i need horizontal scalability i
go to  have a strongly
distributed application and that I need consistency
in transactionality yes then my
product would be cloud spanair if the
requirements are not of that style if what
I want to do is a migration of a
solution of an application that already
exists and let's say the
migration path is easier probably
with cloud sql it
is the right solution and finally if
I do not have relational data the
question is an application oriented to
mobiles or not in this case I would be
using if it is for mobile fire you see
realtime or cloud data store no  yes yes it
is not if it is not like that
very well because with this
I have finished my review I know that very very
quickly of a lot of components
logically if you want to delve into
any of them well both today and
in successive days well we can
talk specifically  From each one of them
now I would like to give way to how I
told our client and partners to
tertsch chat the cloud antonio mont  blanc
who is a software engineer is going
to share with us an experience
of real use of one of these
cloud store components
[Applause]
hello everyone I'm antonio
jose member of the
seattle cloud engineering team and for the next 10 minutes
or so I would like  tell you
how we use one of the solutions that
jose documents, which is cloud storage, so
we have to
rewind part of that component, but I
would like to start with a question to
the public and how many of
you have used
a storage solution currently in production
of
distributed files type nfs or similar
in a few hands I think I'm
getting old already
because in the past
when we were in the position of
implementing a similar solution in fs it
was one of the alternatives that
first came to mind for two main reasons
one of  them is that it is easy to
implement mounting a machine running
on fs is relatively simple.  a simple
matter of minutes a few hours if
we try to set up a cluster
and for another reason that is transparent
for our applications we can have
our fs server a lot of
applications of different kinds that
for them access to the content of a
file in a directory is going to be  identical
or be nfs be be local then because we
consider in seattle that one of the
stories is an interesting alternative
for this type of
traditional distributed storage for
use cases in which the speed of
data access is not critical
before continuing and for  give you a bit
to develop for the context I
tell you about who we are or what we
do that keyboard offers a
tool for a
data migration platform mainly of
contacts and mail between
providers worldwide of people perez
worldwide our main  clients
are google in its branch of web contact and
gmail yahoo and with cast and as
pr  firstly with google and with yahoo we are
integrated with your with your with your
contacts email website in such a way that
practically all users I imagine
that most of those who are
present here today could migrate their email and
their contacts from here to another
provider  to his google and
yahoo accounts as well as comcast
to give us some figures since we
integrated with him about 4
years ago we have helped we have helped to
migrate more than three million
users we have a series quite
quite strict with them we must not
to be available for 99.5
percent of the time, that means that
we cannot be down for more than
three and a half hours a month,
approximately,
we manage to handle traffic peaks
moving mail, mainly up to
the vice per hour,
and we receive about 18,000 operations  of
migration per day for all our clients
that translates into approximately 30 million emails
per day 3 million
co  Contacts and we are integrated with 247
providers worldwide,
so as shown in seattle
cloud, the first use case that is
simpler is as support to
serve static content from our
web pages or cloud storage, it has a
low account and has an interesting
characteristic is that it allows you to
publish content, make
tubasket content for the public and that for
us to put an advantage for two
reasons, one of them is that we do not have
to worry about having a
web server although that content is static or
maintaining it
and on the other hand  any non-
technical person from the company can update
that content manually shavar
thomas directly and dynamically without
having to go through the clutter or
deployment processes or knowing the
peculiarities of the web page that
we are updating,
just check the check must  be pauli
click and of course this generates a link that
looks like this
here cloud storage  will serve that
content respecting the metadata of
the file object this case is an
image an example
they are responsible for keeping
that content available and we do nothing more
than that image of our content on
our website
another use case perhaps a little more
complex  is used as a
temporary storage system for
contact import files in
svb cart formats on our contacts platform it
supports the possibility of
being provided with a file with
contacts in the large format
currently supported by the main
email contact providers with
mail gmail etcetera yahoo
and for us
alternatively for those users
who are more reluctant to
provide us with their
origin account credentials to the user by
passing their access account to hotmail
to migrate their contacts
to legitimate google then it is an
interesting alternative for them
then for what  it will be an idea of the archi
ecture s  simp
we have taken the example of google
contacts here we have a scam a
copy of the capture of the interface as
they were on my website with touch a
user could click on the
contact port option and select a csv
cloud card file that would be uploaded to  our
file service, which is nothing more than
a set of machines
running a web service that would analyze
that file, validate the content and
save it in a package in our
our call storage later,
when the client, in this case, the google
contacts had analyzed, has collected
all  the information necessary to
launch the migration there is a call from
us and we are not going to go into much
detail right
now, it would provide us with that
information of the destination account to
which we must look at the contacts and the
identifier of the file that we must
access so that when  the
migration begins to occur within
the contact platform we would access
the dawn of the file  storage collects that we would
recover that csv file we
process the contacts and
store them in the destination account
you will wonder at this moment how
long you keep that csv file you see it
at some point you save it forever
what we do is delete the
files once it has  When the
migration is finished, we do not do it through an
event that the migration has finished, but we
do give
the file a time to live or dry, it must be
analyzed in case there is a
problem,
I think that as long as it takes, navigation
is difficult to be deleted  for reasons
of economy and for this we must
implement or implant some
automatic mechanism that deletes those
files and that is what Jose was referring to
before when he talked about the talk
we were talking about the country, there is the
faisal that the
cloud d  storage is quite interesting
in fact it can be modified it can be
accessed through the cloud
storage law supports formats in the  type jason
and in xml and in this case you can see for
example how we have defined the rule that
our bcv storage package must apply
to the files that
we want to delete basically the rule is
made up of an action that is delete and
a condition that is that the  If the file
is more than 10 days old, we compare the
facts for 10 days, because perhaps they
should be analyzed.
There is another interesting use case that
we do not apply but that may be of
interest to companies that store
large amounts of
data information and want to economize on
information storage.  and it is in
the capacity or the possible action of
moving an object between different
sectors classes as before the mind
has one thing there are four types multi the in
regional they bring multi-regional regional
in English nick online in this example if
it looks very good
I think I do
n't know  defines an action that would be seven
key sectors for those
basketball files that have to meet the
condition  tion of being in a
regional stories and they are more than 182 days 16
months old we move it to the nearly class and
the same for the class of objects that
are online that are more than 365
days old we would move to code i'm and this
It can be a case of saving
economy for, as I said, for
companies that want to save a lot of
data and with which they do not have a
very strict access requirement,
also, as you
mentioned, you can access live like it and
many other operations that, in general, such as
creating buckets  move data between
back etc
within Wi-Fi and the people of all this
is to make life a little
easier for us, developed a tool that
is that useful that we would simply make
a simple interface command to
access to clean cloud storage here
you can see the  examples for our
case how we could visualize the
content of our life cycle of
our package and contact file in port
how to update the example but from all
the tools  While it provides that
the lost interesting people are used
, it allows you to carry out a
risk assessment of a diagnosis
on the state of your interaction
or your connection with the packages. It
has several diagnostic tools,
one of them is it allows you to evaluate the
latency of the  communication the fraud
read write and you could model
your use case to for example
make the concurrent to your baquet
singular cases a little more intensive
thank you intensive for example partition
'no big files in chang's that are
going to be
uploaded concurrently than for various
tests
neither of modeling would
the package behave before making the decision to
implement our solution within
a back
and finally the slightly rarer use case
that we have klaus is classic is
quite well integrated with
in a way that allows you to  example
import and export data from your
database to a back from a
va that in  our case was very
useful when we decided to migrate from the
first generation claudio injury
to the second generation because in
our classic it is not critical for
our business for us
statistics we were able to create the
new generation database with the second
generation with the same  with the
structure and we generate one of the two
initial ones in the first generation what we will
do in the package and from the bar that
we import it to the second
generation base and apart from that it is also
common to find in the course of
these brackets objects of all  The nature
that people are leaving their
tests behind has become a bit
of a catch-all of objects for the
engineering team in Seattle Cloud exploring,
let's say, new use cases,
but I am left with a reflection and
that is that nowadays it is so cheap to store
data in the cloud that nothing is thrown away
thank you all thank you very
much.
antonio again thank you for your
presence to  attention in the session we will
be here for the rest of the afternoon we
encourage you to also visit the
boxes that we have with specific demos
for our partner who will also be
offering very interesting solutions
I tell you both
Antonio and I are here in case you have
any questions thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]